hey guys were back with a brand new
MacBook Pro with the new 5600 M graphics
and in this video we're gonna be testing
out a bunch of games to see how it
compares in how well it performs and if
you didn't watch the video from
yesterday where we ran a bunch of
benchmarks definitely watch that video
we'll have a link in the description
below or you can wait until this video
is over and click the end screen to
check that out now in that video we
showed off our brand new premium hoodie
now we also have t-shirts like this one
so definitely go down into the merch
shelf and check those two out we've got
Windows 10 boot camp as you guys can see
and I want to show off the OpenCL score
that we got forty-three thousand eight
hundred and eighty-five on Windows
OpenCL
I think in Mac OS we only got like
38,000 OpenCL but we got 43 for metal so
now what I'm gonna do before playing
games in Windows I'm gonna switch back
to Mac OS and we're gonna play some
Fortnight on Mac OS to see how it
performs all right here we are Mac OS
for night we're gonna go all out let's
go full resolution 3k resolution right
here and it auto sets a high with far
high in all these different settings
alright the fans are heating up but I
want to remind you guys about the
resolution that we're playing at now
1440p has about 3.7 million pixels and
we're playing at the MacBook Pros native
resolution which is about 5.9 million so
basically in between 1440p and 4k
alright so seeing as we're at that
resolution this is insane I'm getting
about like 88 fps right now 72 what in
the world
guys come on bro oh my goodness this is
so consistent - I do want to mention
this is the 8 core model with 32 gigs of
ram with the 5600 M oh oh oh my goodness
95 it just hit a hundred FPS at this
resolution in settings alright we're
back on the windows and before we get
into the gaming I want to test out to
more benchmarks Unigine heaven and 3d
marks times pi I want to remind you
we're doing the extreme preset that way
is to say
across all systems all right Wow guys
this score is insane eighty three point
eight is Unigine heaven on Windows 10
computer on Mac OS we got seventy five
point seven so even more and by the way
these are not custom drivers that are
downloaded this is right out of the box
boot camp Windows 10 we didn't do
anything just automatically installed
and we're getting this much performance
3dmark time spy let's run it right here
alright so we just got the score back
five thousand five hundred and seventy
three points in time spy for this new
graphics card with automatic download
Windows 10 bootcamp drivers and looking
at this it says we scored better than
forty three percent of all results and
right above us at fifty seven hundred
points is an RT X twenty sixty laptop
that is just insane that is awesome from
this mobile chip that has a TDP of fifty
watts only so let us know down in the
comment section below how much your
gaming laptop or your desktop PC scored
compared to this guy alright guys here's
for night on Windows 10 and surprisingly
it found the best settings for us which
was native resolution 16 by 10 but it
said everything to epic with a hundred
percent 3d resolution everything's on
epic so let's start out with this
alright so everything maxed out
literally the max that it can be with
native resolution 33 FPS is what we're
getting
it does have some spikes down so
definitely not optimal not where you'd
want it to be I'm gonna switch it to
high but I'm gonna set the 3d res to
100% Hey look at that now we're getting
about 50 fps and just because this
resolutions insane I'm just gonna let it
be at 62% resolution a hundred fps guys
120 fps right there it's up with these
BOTS man get out of here
yeah yeah so all of you guys that are
curious how much performance this would
get at 1080p resolution I actually found
out that if you set that 3d resolution
to 36%
that'll be exactly about 1920 by 1080p
resolution about two point zero seven
million pixels coming from the native
res and I'm just gonna go epic epic
everything and there we have it a
hundred and forty-four fps basically
look goes up to 150
I see 160 sometimes 130 but look at that
you can grab this MacBook Pro what the
5600 M hook it up to a hundred
forty-four Hertz monitor and play
fortnight at 144 FPS this is insane and
not only that but it's at epic epic
everything everything's maxed out at
1080p resolution basically the same
matching pixels alright we're going into
ecology D war zone and so far I can
already tell you guys this is a gaming
Beast
you don't need an e GPU you don't need
the 5700 XT by this thing by itself
because not only other games better but
since its integrated the graphics is
integrated it's gonna be better for
productivity work compared to having the
e GPU where you have the bottleneck of
the Thunderbolt 3 cable alright guys
getting into war zone I'm here in the
settings and I've set the resolution to
1843 by 1152 that's actually two point
one two million pixels higher than 1080p
which is two point zero seven million
alright guys so far a hundred and twenty
four fps 120 alright so about 110 fps
sometimes 115 I did see a go of 240 but
now that I'm walking around it's not so
it is getting close to the performance
of the HP omen with the RT X 2060 not
the max Q Edition
Oh elmo's Adam considering that this is
a 50 watt TDP chip and it's performing
this well that's impressive
oh we got me now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna up the settings to see what
graphics settings we could get at this
resolution at around 60 fps so I'm just
gonna go all out max everything out
anti-aliasing to the max nobody would
really do this but let's try it out all
right guys we're seeing 90 FPS down here
like are you kidding all right out here
88-81
75 96 guys I just turned everything up
to the max even the anti-aliasing is
maxed out fully if you're buying this
thing to do video editing 3d rendering
whatever else and you want to do some
gaming on the side you don't have to go
on behind a GPU you don't have to buy a
gaming PC or laptop just buy this thing
that was bad bro all right guys now I'm
gonna match it up to 1440p resolution
which is 24 72 by 1517 that's basically
three point six eight or around there
million pixels so I'm just gonna switch
it to that without changing any other
settings all right basically 1440p
getting 58 60 61 FPS so basically around
60 FPS average no way did he kill me so
60 FPS average at 1440p resolution
that's actually really impressive and of
course that's not only around 1440p
resolution but everything's maxed out
guys 1440p everything maxed out and as
you guys know war zone is not fully
optimized yet because it's a fairly new
game so now I'm gonna go native native
resolution 3072 by 1920 and I'm just
gonna switch it down to normal and just
turn off a lot of these extra settings
guys 73 FPS native resolution guys
that's a lot of pixels that is
in between 1440p and 4k with the gaming
laptop who plays at high resolutions
like this in between 1440p at 4k really
nobody you know most people especially
for a game like this battle royale war
zone a lot of people play at 1080p or
1440p and as you just saw the FPS that
we got is really impressive and we're
getting close around 50 60 sometimes 70
FPS at this native resolution which is
very high yeah
what's up bro Adam oh we got me who like
I was quick alright guys with all those
games tested I can say that I am
extremely impressed with AMD with the
5600 M especially since it only has a 50
watt TDP and we're getting performance
that good out of this incredibly thin in
MacBook Pro but the fact is that this is
an $800 graphics option upgrade to get
the 5600 M so you're spending a minimum
of $3,200 now if you're a gamer it
probably makes sense to get some other
Windows gaming laptop that's much
cheaper than this and has a RT X 2060 or
something better than that but if you
love Apple you want a MacBook Pro and
you want to do some productivity work
some video editing
whatever else you're trying to do but
you also want a game you could actually
get this 5600 M you don't have to buy an
e GPU you don't have to buy a gaming PC
or a gaming laptop you have one thin
machine the 16 inch MacBook Pro to do
all of it to get insane gaming
performance so I'd say if you're
thinking of going for the 5500 M with
the 8 gigs of memory because you want to
do some gaming on the side I would
strongly suggest if you can just go for
the 5600 M because the performance is
just so much better and in the next
video that I'm gonna do after this video
goes up I'm gonna start working on the e
GPU versus this 5600 M comparison video
that's gonna be coming up probably
tomorrow
hopefully so if you guys are not already
subscribed you can click the circle
above to do so right now and if you did
not watch the benchmark video that went
up tomorrow you can check it out right
over there thanks for watching guys and
be sure to check out our merch right
below this video
[Music]